في وسط محافظه خانيونس تحديدا في شارع
البحر حيث عماره جاسر وهذه المنطقه تعرضت
لتدمير واسع من قبل اليات الاحتلال حيث
تطلق قذائفها باتجاه هذا
الشارع نشاهد في الافق هناك حيث الدخان
الذي يتصاعد نتيجه غاره نفذتها طائرات
الاحتلال على ما يبدو في وسط المحافظه
تحديدا في منطقه ابو حميد والسن الدخان
تتصاعد كما تشاهدون في
الصوره هنا دخان ابيض على ما يبد ايض فيط
منطقه اخرى الى الجنوب من المكان الذي
نتواجد فيه قد تكون عباره عن قنابل دخانيه
اطلقتها اليات الاحتلال في المحاور التي
تتوغل فيها بشكل اكبر وبشكل اعمق تحديدا
في وسط المحافظه منطقه دور ابو حميد وكذلك
منطقه دوار بني سهيله اضافه الى الاجزاء
الجنوبيه الشرقيه من المحافظه سواء في
منطقه معن حتى منطقه حي المناره والى
الغرب من هاتين المنطقتين منطقه جزان
النجار وكذلك الى حدود منطقه البطن السمين
في الاجزاء الشرقيه منها قوات الاحتلال
تطلق قذائفها باتجاه تلك المناطق ونفذت
غارات واسعه خلال الليله الماضيه وحتى هذه
اللحظه دخان ابيض بشكل كثيف جدا في هذه
المنطقه اضافه الى الغارات التي نفذتها
طائرات الاحتلال قبل قليل في وسط محافظه
خانيونس هذا كوات كابتر هذه بتلاقيها
قريبه الحين بتطخ على المدنيين تحت في
البلد عننا فهمت علي فمنطقه تعتبر من هنا
وهيك هذه كلتها منطقه خطا يعني احنا
موقفين هنا عند طورنا بمنع الناس اللي
تنزل تحت كما تستمعون الى اصوات اطلاق
النار بين الحين والاخر اصوات اطلاق النار
هذه ناتجه اما عن اطلاق من قبل طائرات
مسيره اطلق نار من قبل طائرات مسيره او
حتى ان قناصه الاحلال قد يكونوا قد اعتلوا
بعض المنازل المرتفعه في وسط محافظه خن
يوسف وتطلق النار باتجاه كل من يتحرك في
هذه
المنطقه هذه الصوره وهذا هو المشهد في
محافظه يونس بعد ليله كانت حاميه وكانت
فيها قد اشتدت فيها وتيره المعارك ما بين
المقامه الفلسطينيه وكذلك قوات الاحتلال
لقناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر خان
يونس